the presentation today is about
designing augmented reality systems for
speed and a little bit background about
me I currently lead the a our
engineering team and Niantic labs who
are the makers of pokemon go so maybe
you know about that game that made
everyone took the world by storm in 2016
and Niantic acquired actually my company
actual reality at Asha I was a
co-founder and CTO where we were
building the technology for AR that we
actually continued to do so at Niantic
prior to that I've been building large
scale machine learning systems and
computer vision systems since 2012 and
prior to that I worked as a as a data
scientist at Intel labs and also at on-q
TV which was a spun off from Intel and
then to Verizon now we're gonna start
with this so they're only really two
hard problems in computer science right
yeah by the cache invalidation is very
hard to name things and projects of
course having that cool mythical name
for your open-source project it matters
and of course one-off errors so thus in
the field of our computer science and
then the question is why is augmented
reality so hard why is it that I don't
see different people wearing your super
cool AR headsets or having AR or VR be
pervasive it's still very much on the
fringe why don't we see it today so
there's many reasons part of it that
all's plain in a Bettis is actually
really really hard to build this for
many reasons because AR is such an
interdisciplinary field it needs many
many areas and areas of expertise so
before that you've seen how in a lot of
technology we've seen how sci-fi
sometimes we consider the product
roadmap for a lot of Technology and for
AR is really this book by Vernor Vinge
rainbow Zen where he talks about this
future where everyone has retina contact
lens where reality you subscribe to a
different reality and his augment
and you live in this world and but but
the realities are most normal people in
the world if you've noticed sci-fi I
really don't really know about AR and
most people actually heard about
augmented reality like maybe your
children your parents grandparents or
random person in the street they know
about AR because of this game that
Niantic build that put it in a map even
there wasn't as high-tech as what it was
depicted in this sci-fi book it was good
enough to spark the imagination of
people so right now we are in the
company building and pushing that vision
forward so now I'm going to explain why
ar is so hard so part one in order to
augment reality you need to very first
understand the world in order to augment
it and this is really the field of
computer vision that takes images and
understands the environment and what
you're seeing here is an image of
segmentation semantic understanding
where in computation you can for the
application of AR there's really two
level of understanding this is really at
the high level at the meaning knowing
that this particular blob of pixel is a
car as a road is a tree and etc and the
challenge here is that semantic
understanding has really been started to
be solved somewhat at the object
recognition level with deep learning and
even with deal learning we're still at
the beginning of it we haven't really
crossed to full AI understanding of the
world so it'll is still very challenging
and Eve learning today needs to run on
GPUs which are super super big and take
a lot of power and they're not gonna fit
in your pocket they're probably gonna
burn a hole in your pocket so there's
that so the other part of understanding
the world is more at the low level which
you don't hear maybe as much is more at
the level of perception of geometry
really understanding sort of the 3d
Nest's 3d ness of the world knowing a
certain blob around here is something
that I should avoid and something is far
or close and a lot of this world
actually comes from robotics so robots
navigating through the world they don't
really know that something is a chair or
no they just know that I want to avoid
it an up bump it
- it does what your Roomba does it is a
bit more rudimentary they have kind of
the pumper sensor plus some of the laser
and some of them have a fancy GPS but
they really don't understand that oh
this is a cat or a dog or this is a
bookshelf it just looks like a blob
thing so that's a start of a feel for
understanding the world and what you see
here is an image of a sequence of images
of camera frames trying to infer that
this particular point that I saw a frame
0 and then a frame 1 and then 2 and time
3 it's the same point but there are
different positions once you start
navigating and moving about the world
and that's the same problem in they are
because you have either let's say your
headset or your camera moving around and
even though in each sequence of images
there a different point in space but
there will be in different distances
from where you are in time 0 versus time
3 so the other hard challenge number 2
is the need to run in real stock real
time and this challenge has origins from
the fearless what I was mentioning
earlier in the field of robotics for
sensor fusion and algorithms like slam
not this kind of slam dunk but more the
slam in simultaneous localization and
mapping or Vince which has to do with
navigating in the world so one of the
aspects why this is so challenging is
that certain tasks need to run locally
and on the device for to hit the
performance requirements so that you
don't break the suspend suspense of
disbelief that you are there in this
interacting with this digital object as
truly there and why this is hard just to
put it in perspective the camera feed of
raw image let's say HD which is 1080 by
720 is at 30 frames per second is
roughly 600 megabits per second of
processing data raw data and that's a
lot to processing that phone if you
really put it in perspective of how
amazing progress we've done so far so
part of it is taking this super high
bandwidth data and processing into
something that you can understand what I
mentioned in part one is understanding
the world and part of this just going a
bit deeper into what
lamb is is really this computational
problem problem or constructing or
updating this map of the world that you
want to navigate it and in a sense is a
bit of a chicken and egg and problem
because I say it's sort of a your drop
in to know where you don't have any
vision and you only see a little bit of
what you've seen and start building an
internal map so that's the part of our
why it's called slam is simultaneously
localizing know where you knowing where
you are plus mapping building this map
as you traverse and there's lots of
proper popular approximate solutions
among them there's particle filter
extended Kalman filters graph slam or
more in the category that you see a lot
with air kid and air core more visual
odometry and vent systems which has to
do with using your IMU your gyro and a
cèlle meter 2 plus the visual data to
start building roughly where you are in
the world so how these map of the world
look like is something like this so this
is actually a map built with a robot
that's navigating round through the
street and it's really much sort of a
point cloud created from features of the
raw video feed so imagine kind of taking
a walk down the block around here taking
all that video in real time and
converting it into this points and
features so that's what slam does now
number three wise part still augmented
reality yet another field so we brought
coop division we brought robotics and
then the need to display competi
compelling digital objects in the real
world and this is really the field of
computer graphics so it's really
marrying computer vision robotics
graphics in order to create believable
objects that blend into the world and
the challenge is creating objects that
can blend in with the lighting variation
that we have in the real world because
lighting sources in the world bear you a
lot and you don't know how to render it
properly so I was at SIGGRAPH and I saw
a really impressive advances right now
there's already work with real-time ray
tracing which is amazing but of course
they had this ginormous
upu lots of GPUs to get it done but do
it in AR in this tiny cellphone is not
gonna happen to be able to create
something so realistic and render and
believable so there's still a lot of
work to be done there now
the other challenge of course is the
need to create applications in a
seamless way so this is more the
developer experience so you have all
these challenging fundamental fields
with computer vision graphics robotics
and how do you blend on all of these
together and create a our experiences
and this has to do with the field of
game development game development
happens to be naturally where a lot of
developers naturally think in 3d so a
lot of popular tools today environments
a unity and unreal already have tons of
tooling around for AR and VR development
another of api's are coming around for
that
but unfortunately best practices and
development cycle they are still not
quite there yet it's actually quite
challenging to create to create a our
apps you could have a development cycle
of about 5 to 15 minutes because the the
challenge is that a normal game
development normal fully virtual you
have a game box where you define the
boundaries of your room and where
everything is but for AR the room is the
real world and the real world is sort of
infinite because you don't know where
the user is going to navigate so the
valance cycle becomes hard because you
need to deploy to the phones and the
abstractions for developers haven't been
there yet to think about a reason
how do we develop for AR and VR so those
are not quite there there yet so this is
a whole different talk on how to develop
for AR and what we're doing to iterate
faster so we're working on some areas on
here but that's a little bit separate
now of course you need to kind of put
all these things together and somehow
make it work together and fit it in this
or in this and of course that if that's
all those fields by themselves are not
hard enough we have to make them fit and
run fast so then this brings me to there
are only n to the infinity heart
problems that augmented reality to name
a few is really the hardest one is
real-time computation and tiny devices
so that's the foundational on designing
systems around that really hard
algorithms that takes PhDs to design one
many Peters needs to design one
algorithms yet to be discovered because
we still don't have fully reliable
algorithms that understand the dynamics
of the world so that you have the slam
map that it built so what if as you're
building that map someone moves the
bench or moves a couch and that was part
of your map how do you handle that and
then when you come back what do you do
or lighting variations because a lot of
this light on dark or whether we as
humans were able to discern that but is
really hard for computer vision systems
to do that and working indoors and
outdoors and all the variations between
hardware devices so let alone the
variations between right now iOS and
Android and between them there's already
sensor variation that are very sensitive
to the algorithms let's say they have a
different isola meter calibrated
differently or how the calls are done or
they even the camera parameters because
they all have different camera sensors
that might have distortions in them and
they do affect the algorithm so how do
we handle all these challenges so it's
hard so this is why we don't see the
sci-fi version or everyone walking
around with a our headsets yet because
it's very hard so now there's a bit of
hope so how do we go about and reasoning
about the future so one thing I want to
bring up is um there's a kumys law so
this is beyond Moore's law Moore's law
at this point right so cuckoo is law is
is a state set at a fixed computing load
the amount of battery you need will fall
by a factor of two every year and a half
so that is very significant because that
means we will get the same amount of
processing but a fraction of the battery
of the battery and for example this is
actually a real benchmark the iPhone 7
it scores better on both single and
multi-core benchmarks than any MacBook
Air mate since 2000 I guess 17 and
actually come compute and performs just
as good as a
13 MacBook Pro so your phone iPhone 7
it's just as good as your MacBook Pro
from 2013 so there's something to think
about that and this really has exploding
and implications in computing devices
becoming smaller and more mobile and
with more processing so that we can fit
more computation in them and they are
becoming a important factor in terms of
economics of also data centers becoming
more efficient so there's two sides of
it so in the future and this is a quote
by actually Richard Fineman calculated
back in 1985 that based on physics law
the efficiency of computation should be
around hundreds of millions of billions
and since then about I guess this
calculation was done maybe at 2016 only
about a factor forty thousand we've only
achieved a factor of 40,000 based on
manufacturing and the hardware so
there's there a long room to grow until
we hit the theoretical limits of physics
so that's exciting now the other thing
that we have on our hand on predicting
the future is a Holmes law that the
three telecommunication categories with
wireline wireline in terms of USB Wi-Fi
or nomadic nomadic would call it as
cellular March altogether exponentially
Omer at a lockstep and their data rates
increase in a similar exponential curve
meaning that the slower rates like
cellular trail just behind the faster
ones so what this means for example is
that you can now routinely achieve
cellular data speeds that match the best
of dial-up in 1990s I know that isn't
sound too exciting this dialogue but but
we're getting there I mean we're getting
to the point where phones are really
starting to look like computers that the
capabilities of them so that's that's
that's connect setting and the more
interesting thing about here if you can
extrapolate beyond is that forward in
the case the convergence
actually Wireless and cellular that is
interesting which means that in the
future we could have speeds in cellular
in our cell phones data rates that are
just as fast as the top season Wi-Fi and
the reason why is because at the end
they all are based on the same physics
just radios so there's no reason why
cellular should be slower than Wi-Fi
this is just infrastructure and we are
already seeing this trend this is only
going up to 2015 but 2020 around 2020
roughly a lot of the telecoms are
working on pushing 5d and 5g is supposed
to have 10 gigabits data rates so
imagine a world where you have mobile
devices that could have data access
speeds of 10 gigabits what could we do
different because that's also as almost
as fast as a lot of our wireless or
Wi-Fi speeds at home so that changes
things so at some point though we'll
reach some fundamental human limit where
we want more speed but why do we want
more speed and data rates is all to push
more data for processing and consuming
information and data so there's also
another extrapolation that at some point
will reach them fundamental human limit
that the our human eyeballs can process
only so many pixels per second and at
that point if wireless data transfer
rate hit that human pixel eye processing
rate we won't need anymore wired
connections because Wireless will be
sufficient for everything because right
now the highest bandwidth data
consumption for us is really a visual
information so taking all these
components how should we really design a
our systems that are in a sense robust
for the future and as part of that is
kind of taking the trends and our
cellphones are starting to look really
much in terms of processing and
capabilities like desktop computers or
servers even servers so part of that is
in terms of programming and building
system
we should really have just stand on
shoulders of giants and use the
abstractions that we learned as an
industry as a whole and just use them
and apply them to developing software
for mobile devices or form for a our
systems so I think this is an exciting
time to work in AR because this is a
convergence of where the technology
trends are going and where is early
enough to start building and making a
lot of progress so with that we'll talk
a little about systems designs principle
for distributed system so taking that
idea of now phones are looking starting
to look like servers why don't we
program it like servers so concepts and
servers good principles is a decreasing
processing time of computation so that
you can handle more requests and with
that for example you have colocation so
that you can reduce any overhead
associated with fetching data required
for processing at work or collocating
the data near the code so how do we do
that or caching a lot of caching we
spend a lot of time thinking about
caching so caching and abstractions for
that also applied for AR how do we do
that or the concept of remoting so
reducing the time spent accessing remote
services so for example we've have done
a lot of interfaces that are more
coarse-grained and part of that
sometimes we remoting with seeing many
level structures of accessing data is
like CDN in between your so in between
your actual cloud where is hosted and
CDN and then your actual accessing to
fetch the data there so applications
around there or charting so charting has
to do with truly stateless components
that can simply be scaled out and the
work can be balanced between them
so in in distributed systems you have
this whole whole concept how do we sharp
processes so that you don't have hot
spotting and do that properly and have
as much as possible I unit distribute
uniform distribution right and the other
big one is really concurrency to achieve
scalability and in particular in this
world where we're going into many many
many many data many many servers running
and also many many course it is
important to be able to program in
concurrently so part of it is like
pooling resources to reduce the overhead
associated by moving things around too
much parallelization by decreasing time
to compute a particular unique unit of
work decomposed and done at the same
time and as much as possible try to not
have any locks in your code that's hard
if you're trying to do a multi-threaded
programming try to minimize the
contention of share resources by really
thinking and reasoning about the
critical paths on your code and
concurrency is um it's very hard we
still don't have it right but there's
been models now in the industry where
we've learned and done better so with
that the one Timon mapping on how we
applied as an AR decreasing processing
time is really trying to achieve that
principle of real time processing
because this whole thing about a are
processing frames and having that as
much as possible hit 30 frames per
second you really want to be the real
time and a pride as many concepts in
decreasing processing time the other one
is as you enter a world of many many
devices you can start thinking about
them and maybe sharing some of the
computation of your collocate in the
same place like in Pokemon go rate
you're all togetherness in place maybe a
concept of charting its mark charting
and of course scalability via
concurrency and on this we are moving in
the world where Moore's law is not
necessarily scaling as much in the
single core it's very much multi-core I
mean iPhone right I guess a lot of
mobile devices now are at least six or
eight cores so that has to do with how
do we do learning some of the best
practices with lock-free programming or
actor models which are mostly applied
and distributive system but I haven't
seen them much in apply to mobile
devices so today's talk I'm going to
only just focus on one of the aspects
for
we apply some of the concepts for
real-time in the networking and also
with concurrency so those are the two
that will tackle there's a lot more they
could cover but don't have as much time
so speeding up networking the whole
thing about AR is that AR is really in
life is in real time and AR you're
experiencing in the real world and
interacting so you really do need this
this real-time aspect because as you get
the camera feet of 30 frames per second
you have to have a response time
depending on the different applications
within a frame which really means a
response time of 33 milliseconds which
is very low so how do we achieve that so
now I'm gonna play a demo of some of the
work we've done and what you're gonna
see here is actual game footage of a
multiplayer AR puzzle-solving game and
in here actual players are cloaked in an
avatar they look almost as if they were
rigged to follow a pre-planned path but
in reality our multiplayer AR technology
has such a low latency and so good that
it's just the tracking on their phones
by tracking me the camera position of
their phone in AR it's just it's just
connected to the phone and that's how it
just works and what you see are our
players interacting in a physical
physical way with the digital objects
and this is all possible because of the
reaction time and processing that it all
feels real and they're pulling and
turning having statues around here
and in this part it looks funny when
you're not in AR just looks people
walking around but when you're there is
actually quite fun so the thing that's
fun about here is that everyone is
sharing the same reality together at the
same time and they need to work together
at the same time at the end here to
paddle this oh I guess they paddled
energy to paddle the energy orb in a bit
here to unlock the puzzle that you just
saw so what is cool about here is really
low latency multiplayer a are working so
how do we go about building at least a
network layer for that so we have a
couple design choices in here so we have
not real-time choices of technology
real-time we have the ability to send
messages over the wire over the network
either reliable messages or unreliable
so in the world of reliable messages you
have but but not real time you have HTTP
or rest
which is easy to scale there's tons of
infrastructure already to develop here
easy to code lots of reports but it
doesn't meet our real-time requirements
for AR with WebSockets
is it's somewhat real-time but not as
real-time it has really hundreds of
milliseconds of latency when you have a
centralized server that's deploy
somewhere and uses still the web stack
technology that could be somewhat
heavyweight for what we need because in
here we're just sending a lot of
computer vision data which could be very
small a lot smaller than we don't need
that whole header for for what it would
be good maybe for part of the problem or
sharing the error maps but not
everything so now we have this other
world of more real time but with
unreliable messages which is really fast
well okay yeah you you don't want to
decide for that quadrant on the on the
other and there where is really like
slow and not real-time and unreliable
messages are really the US postal office
so we don't design for that but just
just to make it fit a full 2x2 but going
back to UDP we have can be really fast
can we use a via peer-to-peer but the
problem with in AR or games is that it's
bad for server authority or anti-cheat
it requires also advanced techniques to
share to send very large messages
because UDP protocol has in order to be
fast you you want to fit certain size of
messages so our ideal solution would be
somewhere there somehow magically we
to be cross-platform we wanted to run on
all cell phones with I have limited
resources we wanted to be able to send
small and large messages we want to be
able to work on all networks Wi-Fi LTE
or bad signal connections like 3d or
two-year cetera and to enable real time
so how do we go about designing for that
space so first of all there's no magic
bullet that fits in both the way we
solve this is having actually using both
pieces kind of a combination of TCP and
UDP so a little bit about how that works
regular regular cloud applications today
you the for let's say we're to build
this a lab where you're sharing this
avatar and camera post position to
everyone in the game cell phone one
sends my a are tracking position to the
cell tower and the cell tower back to
the server and the server might be
somewhere far away like in Virginia or
Iceland or who knows where and then back
from the server to cell tower back to my
friend who's just next to me and playing
with me and the whole round trip really
takes in the order of magnitude more
than hundreds of milliseconds and of
course by then you're you will already
have moved and it will be late and the
whole experience will just look bad so
this won't work so what we've done
actually is with our technology we got
rid of the hop to the cloud and
stablished that peer-to-peer network
between phones so they just talked to
the cell tower so our technology
optimizes for real time a art that chief
Slayton sees that are in the tens of
milliseconds in this way you're when
you're sending your camera position in a
hour I'm sending it to cell tower and
directly back to to my phone to my
friend who's next to me and the nice
thing the property about a artists nice
is that is somewhat guarantee that
you're gonna go through the same cell
tower because you're somewhat co-located
you're physically next to your friends
it's very likely that you're gonna ping
them in the same cell tower so that's
nice plus and to put this into
perspective at this point when you're
rendering I guess as I mentioned in 30
frames per second you need a response
time of 33 milliseconds so within the
solution a peer-to-peer you do
to get the a our data just in time and
fit within that budget period and this
way you can achieve extremely low
latencies and you can see where your
friend is not where they where if you
were to do the other solution now how
the architectural starts looking starts
looking something like this when you
start building let's say there's seven
phones in a game it is a peer-to-peer
network so they're all fully connected
like a mesh network and they also talk
to the server form or the server
authority pieces of it and to enable
sending larger messages so this looks
awfully familiar to some of the diagrams
of how different data center layouts or
services are when you start having fully
connected notes of servers talking to
each other and sending data because they
have a very fast network they can rely
on and what we're expecting in here is
in the future we'll get there where
we'll all have a very fast network and
this will just work I mean today is
actually working - it'll work better
right yeah so now the other pieces that
I'm going to talk about is speeding up
computation so I think I mentioned a
little bit how computer vision is hard
and there's still lots of research and
PhDs working on solving tons of problems
so at a high level one of the core
problems in augmented reality what I
mentioned earlier is this concept of
understanding and building this map of
the world with with slam at a very high
level I'm kind of abstracting lots of
blocks in here many many many blocks at
a high level how they are slam
computation pipeline look this is really
really high level that 10,000 bird leaf
per view of it you have sort of your
camera and image inputs coming in and
then you have this computation block
that tracks features because you don't
want this super high bandwidth data you
extract it into some matrix this is a
lot more lower dimension and that gets
passed into two blocks either your
localization computation or your mapping
so you're doing both simultaneously
localizing and mapping and then they're
both kind of writing to the air map
you see how this becomes really hard to
program if you do it just regular
sequential programming or the naive way
of just putting blocks around them it
comes very part and just to give you an
idea in terms of the numbers this is a
paper that came out this year
embedding slam and they did a benchmark
on a couple of algorithms for slam
running on different hardware what you
see here there's the desktop
there's laptop there's the TX 1 which is
the Jetson GPU embedded device there's
the X u 4 they all draw X the Odroid
imx6 which is another kind of embedded
device with a arm a 9 architecture panda
yes which is another also embedded
architectures so to extrapolate how this
looks for phones or in the future a our
headset is somewhere between the
somewhere between the light cyan yellow
red or or dark red so those are the
expectations perspective computation
that would run if you try to run this
this is a whole one cycle of it so it
could be as bad as one second and by
that time you have already lost you will
miss your budget for real-time AR there
are other algorithms that are more in
the hundreds of milliseconds with fast
lam 2.0 but there's definitely
trade-offs with that the accuracy of
that is not as high but you trade it off
for speed but what if you wanted to
still have the high quality maps that
are created either for algorithms like
Earth lam or or linear slam how could
you still have really high quality
algorithms but without compromising the
computation so the reality is that all
these algorithms when you implement them
they all look like this because that's
sort of the naive implementation the
easy sir let's just put mutex everywhere
and then wait and then everything is
kind of busy waiting in loops a lot of
times so what if we took some of the
best practices and distributed systems
programming and concurrency and apply
things like actor models
right so the thing what the principal
actor models is that CPUs are now
getting in a faster and what's happening
is that now we just have more cores and
we need to be better at programming
concurrently so the actor model is
really motivated by the highly parallel
computing machines and hundreds of them
and independent independent
microprocessors that you want to as much
as possible isolate the computation so
at a high level conceptual way character
models work you split out your
computation into actors which all have
maintained their own internal state that
is not mutated by anyone else and the
way you do synchronization is be a
message passing and the actor models are
available in many of the great languages
that we know they're an airline they're
an elixir and libraries like akka or
celluloid for Ruby or you could actually
also 0 mq and the nice thing about them
is that you are able to achieve
brokenness topologies that are recite
and resilient to failures and
synchronization points also are
expensive and bad for scalability and
here you cut them down into just message
passing into that core unit so so so
that is enough message passing is enough
for concurrency so now if you were to
program this world and restructure that
that slam algorithm that I show you how
it really now looks it looks like this
at a very high level there's many many
more actors in reality when we implement
this but at very high level now
everything becomes an actor and you have
message queue at the center passing all
the messages around so that you're now
have your image feed and sensor data as
its own actor sending the data and
structuring as you need it and writing
it into the message queue and then the
features factor goes on its own time and
there's no really busy waiting and then
the localization actor or mapping actor
just consumes off of the message queue
and then I think about actors is that
you
can think of them as each of them having
like a mailbox and each of the messages
actually process sequentially and the
nice thing about them is you could now
scale them up I have many many of many
many threats during the future structure
are many many threats doing the
localization actor or the mapping actor
another two at the end you have your
internal database that you're writing to
to yourself to maintain the state of
this air map that you're building and
and this is how I an exactly we had the
initial version of our Slamdance vio
algorithm that was not real time and
then when we didn't change any
algorithms we didn't discover any new
math didn't discover any new computer
vision exact same computation
restructure it better architecture and
better abstractions first of all the
code is easier to work with easier to
read and maintain and test because you
have these integer individual blocks and
we achieve speeds up of five times just
restructuring the code by removing all
the locks on the busy waiting so
previously there's this diagram doesn't
do it justice but there's a lot of busy
waiting a lot so that was one of the
powers of bringing the concepts of
programming distribute systems into the
world of AR so I gotta get credits and
thanks to a lot of these concepts for
this talk to Pete Turner who's in my
team and learning a lot of about this
abstraction it's and also to the rest of
the team for the AR engineering and
Niantic and thanks
so we're also hiring if you're
interested working in actor models for
AR you can either pick me or apply
directly and send a note about it so I
think thank you
[Applause]